gottardo todo
obrigada por estarem a este vídeo que
fazer alguma coisa diferente é não sei
se vocês já ouviram falar sobre uma
organização que chama sapana quem ouviu
ponha a mão no ar cai poucas pessoas
atinge a eu quis trazer vos o meu alô
mais a mais negrume já vão gostar porque
no ano 2009 eu trabalhava nas nações
unidas trabalhava numa agência das
nações unidas contra a filmar em 2010
foi um ano para o nepal tibete e em dia
não chega às portas em 2011 de
entrevistas nos página criada mais
crítico pai desde outubro chegará a
portugal 5 durante o período em que
estive nas terras asiáticas tudo
acontecia sem que eu tivesse tempo para
ter consciência
sinto que também quanto mais eu pensar
naquela altura mais sentia e tudo aquilo
que queria era não sentir
tinha medo de descobrir que era guarda
no final de contas acabei por seu quanto
mais sinto mais próxima da verdade não é
fácil
cada vez é mais complexo e mais raro
muitas questões não foram feitas sobre
aquilo que fiz ou deixei de fazer nem ia
tudo que ele possa dizer é pouco
eu pelo menos nunca será o suficiente
quero espanha no meu lugar e tudo isso
tem com os dizeres por meu pior defeito
até então eu era um ser não senti dor
imagina viver toda minha vida em que
todos os sentimentos e emoções sensações
são 20 talvez a 50%
era eu se não sente não testa e isso é
triste porque só quanto acho é que
realmente vive são neste momento que não
é possível do qual educador de estranhos
podem ser meus críticos parentes vocês
não foram capazes no desejo entendo
vocês próprios viver uma vida e não
a felicidade é triste saber disto mas ao
mesmo tempo é minha possibilidade de
curar esta doença que banha site a nível
social
todo este mal escrito com o objetivo de
de vos transmitir o que estava encerrada
no calão você dificilmente não foi bem
vista em cima
foi tudo pensado eu quer estas o leão
quer ser eu mesma quer ver o circo em
ação de uma vez por todas a verdade é
carolina sem medo e pânico sentir quer
ser eu e quero fazer com que você sinta
necessidade de serem vocês mesmos
a minha frente porque é isto mais ou
menos com cinco pessoas na minha vida
obrigada por não terem ouvido para o
mosquito
eu tenho 24 anos tinha chegado de um
país de uma cultura quando motivação
genital feminina de direitos humanos
a mulher ser violada e vocês agora não
sai sem possuir no facebook as várias
vítimas de violação em grupo
nós quando vemos estou vivo nós quando
temos a consciência que existe muito
mais do que nossa meta e significância
nós treinamos e no meu caso feito
aconteceu com 102 possibilidade
eu sei que vou morrer o que eu vou fazer
para mudar o mundo não está inserida
segundo com você no mastro réus por
favor saia prateada
eu escolhi não ser uma fruta e tenha
certeza ia o toque de hoje chamas nem
igual eu ia sair eu sou igual a vocês e
vocês iguais a mim
obrigada por este tipo de 5 convosco
deixem de transmitir o que eu tenho
feito o que eu tenho tentado fazer com
uma equipa extraordinária para mudar o
mundo
agora
run 2011 seis meses fechados na caça
terapia uma casa no baleal além e se
bobear ele maravilha maravilha não se
conhece golear a uma praia que chama a
uma galera eu estava vivendo uma foto de
uma casinha em com pessoas da argentina
equipa sorte de fazer na altura a indica
sal mas acima de tudo conseguir destruir
nem tudo é assim que todo cliente que
quer construir novo e que foi importada
foi importante por uma simples razão
hoje em dia a postura que eu tenho a ver
se a sociedade quer aos riscos aos
membros e sinto que ainda prefere viver
ou não viver sentir ao não sentir feliz
comigo lembrada pelas pessoas no seu
funeral quando falarem que o que tu que
elas digam software prêmio nobel da paz
logo a partida além disso uma parte
chave mas para além disso eu quero criar
50 que eu vinha sendo que estava sendo
que andava sempre caminhava um grande
objetivo dela era do cap's hoje mas não
é pelo eco tem nada a ver com isso
quando dispusesse testes todos no meu
lado mais frágil lado mais negro meu
lado mais vulnerável à e beleza da
vulnerabilidade extraordinário é que
esta força policial escrito estudantes e
hoje quando jovem disseram que não sabem
o que querem da vida
grata por isso o bronze
tenha certeza que vão conseguir seu
pedro genézio vistoria já tem cinco
filhos
por favor faça x deus era por favor
acesse imenso 2011 isto é ministrado das
nações unidas em áreas não licitadas
nações unidas empreendorismo em áreas de
finanças estratégia porque quero passar
essa mensagem
meu background psicologia clínica
finanças estratégia empreendorismo todas
estas competências e se importa final
foi mesmo este que ser com que um tiro
nas cãs o que massa que eu sou feito foi
muito tempo tem sido muito o que eu
estou eternamente grata achava que o
qual foi o ponto primordial da
universidade das nações unidas meu
professor 18 vanguart com ela eu gosto
finalmente disse o seguinte
crowley não vistas do projeto é bom e
vamos começar do projeto e um digamos um
projeto bom gosto e não 21 é bom krona
vai tocar nos algumas mas como eu tinha
medo em que o projeto é bom conversar
porque nós a fertel eu sonho em missão é
só isso que importa
genário 2012 quatro co fundador fundaram
é que o que eu chamo um sonho e estou na
sony pois uma organização que hoje em
dia eu quero que saibam lidar em
referência à portuguesa no mundo sem
sombra de dúvidas nos casos estamos no
centro do mundo da história da ponta da
europa já não se aguenta a não ser lenta
ponta da europa ou mão em desculpa
desculpa desculpa em termos agora este
domingo é provável mas mas já consegui
aguentar tanta velotti já vale a nossa
senhora
você se inscreveram se um dia com 29
graus
estão aqui ouvir de mim estou a ouvir
vários jovens eram várias vão continuar
você escrever vocês querem saber você
acredita no positivo
vocês acreditam na mudança muitas vezes
não sabem como fazê lo na trabalho como
é que nós estamos a fazer só para
trabalhar em portugal em dia está a dar
pequenos passos ou a língua ela se
quiserem fazer lá eu faço não desligar
mas quiserem trabalhar conosco por favor
digam que partida empate nas nossas
idéias nós estamos disponíveis
e agora o que precisamos fazer é que
ainda não parou de falar venham nós
queremos que ela fala sapato em 3 acho
primeira vez que eles têm público no
nosso site não tá
primeiro acho o alecrim
tá é que o que eu fiz na uma galera
comigo mesmo
que exemplo trazer à população exemplo
prático ao mar na conferência da
microsoft e de uma famosa organização
foi quem assinada
advinha aí brilhante a executar essa
estas duas estas duas em que dados das
duas organizações das duas empresas que
eu vou conseguir a eset empresa
as duas empresas juntaram e fizeram uma
conferência em 2012 não se lembram que
era isso to business
na aula magna e no final nesta
conferência eu nunca foi pauta com 12
anos no solo e outro por favor não vão
ver no youtube que a única pessoa que se
enganam era indiana gestante mil
brilhante não estava não estava na água
gelo é mais tarde estava giro obviamente
é uma mãe não vê o nosso deputado
consciência de qual foi o tema que é só
para não ter que explicar porque o
cálculo é que haja desemprego o
desemprego é tocar toda a gente toca
jovens nos toca sério é que a tocar as
pessoas discutam com 55 horas de vôo em
frente tocando tocando porque não te
providencie a subsistência certa mas eu
tinha que chegar lá e quem é que chegar
lá não tem emprego mas quem chega lá
porque os dons que todos vocês não
acreditarem os talentos de levar o nosso
mundo acho todos os anos usaram
escolhemos o tema continuamos a
trabalhar como no segundo as chamas em
powerpoint capacitação
qual foi o nosso primeiro jogo de copa
a linha z manual todas as miniaturas é
isso mesmo os empregados e desempregados
não é a pessoa mais ativa neste sábado
desempregados estimado informou sobre a
vida melhor
coragem desempregado nós trabalhamos
empregados como é que nós vamos
trabalhar dobrado pela ordem de ideias
que eu fiz com saias por aqui o meu lado
mais vulnerável a uma seca o efeito que
fizeste quinto kercher daqui 50 como é
que vejo um dito que chegar quanto ponto
forte
como é que o que se recordava ea uma
metodologia que vai trabalhar as pessoas
à nossa taxa de sucesso e agora tenho a
honra de dizer em primeira mão
chegou hoje a caixa de entrada está
provado
temos uma taxa de sucesso de 70%
superior a 70% em cada 100 desempregados
independentemente da faixa etária 70
estão ou criar o seu negócio estou a
trabalhar para o outro
por quê porque trabalhamos com pessoas e
é consequência do desemprego é uma casa
é só no caso da chave os dons eu jogo
entra em uma entrevista trabalho sabendo
que uma secção feito num eu senhora que
não vai entregar ele tem que saber que é
trabalhar aqui eu já me candidatar pois
você ver se estou nem aí não dá certeza
para onde assunto como comprova sua
empresa tiver livre no site vocês
precisam por exemplo de minha função é
um desafio é vendam
ainda bem que tem cinco minutos para
reverter este conselho não se vendam a
história mais comerciais sejam melhor
forçando vocês mesmos
ninguém disse que era fácil coitadas das
pessoas que acreditam que a vida vai ser
fácil
ob positivo vez antes de sermos
otimistas sejamos realistas tenhamos
plena consciência não é que nós queremos
chegar
acreditem neste uma vez por todas não há
ninguém nesta sala que não tem a certeza
que vai mudar o mundo à sua maneira mas
a única pessoa pode acreditar em si só
ou seja é única um único papel
fundamental
peço-vos isso por favor eu preciso
tantos de vocês como vocês vão precisar
de mim mas eu preciso de você
isto é um facto
sapana é uma organização não
governamental para o desenvolvimento em
portugal é um conceito que tem sido
aquilo muito tinha uma empresa social
tenha ouvido falar em saná que se
posicionar como uma empresa de emissão o
que quer dizer a uma missão a missão é
transformar o mundo
mas esse mundo vai ser transformado de
uma forma como sustentável como é que
vai ser sustentável
nós criamos um dos heróis pela primeira
vez como disse num episódio no nosso
site não está qualquer informação que
vocês desejam faz questão de passar e de
estar com você
o nosso serviço de consultoria e o nosso
modelo de negócio é que o tronco querem
era possível existência do conceito b
corp junção das melhores práticas do
setor privado ao setor não aproveita se
desculpa e setor social
depois há outro consegue chamar chefe de
economia em português agora deixe comia
convergente autorização das minhas
práticas setor público setor privado e
setor social sapanet sérgio quer ser um
exemplo em portugal quer ser como
trabalhando com organizações de
influência em sendo elas do setor social
pública ou privada
temos um caso específico nós temos
vários investidores ou nós damos um
retorno neste momento são de 20
colaboradores uma organização que em
tempos de cash flow este ano vai quem
atingir um valor superior a 200 mil
euros na altura do campeonato a tensão
muscular
temos dois anos é na ala pode parecer
pouco ganhar e é pouco muito pouco
agora estamos a começar pelo prêmio
nobel da paz precisa de um milhão de
pessoas impactadas
mas nós eu garante uma coisa vos a minha
palavra de honra
eu não faço pra vocês porque eu sou
egoísta porque eu tenho certeza daquilo
que mexe pra fazer qual é minha missão
o de que quer ficar agora são vocês é
menos dinheiro
são vocês que estão dissipadas
sou desempregado seus recursos que nós
trabalhamos são a salvar ideias e sem
universidade sem água potável na índia
que nós trabalhamos é o projeto ninguém
que estamos a construir um ao quintal da
e sustentável num paraíso na terra que
são mais que vem 25 escritórios a falar
em casa paraná é pressão vão ser mais eu
não quero ver mais essa paraná
o que eu quero vender hoje é o quinto há
uma certeza absoluta é que todos nós
vamos morrer
segundo a certeza e depressa minha vida
vai aumentar
por favor faça o quê agora a sério quem
me pergunta nações unidas ao paraná
imagina ter 80 anos a trabalhar nas
nações unidas não imagina sapana até
ostentar de tempo a emissão partilha
acreditem e tenho a certeza dos quentes
quando vocês responderem estas duas
perguntas malu acorda da mesma maneira
está no caminho certo sofrer sim querem
trabalhar para onde vou
sim estou no caminho certo muito grata